hey guys it's justine and today we're
talking about the brand new ipad pro 2
that just came
out i'm really excited about this thing
and i've been testing it out for the
past couple of weeks and this thing is
amazing i told you i was going to do a
follow-up video for my unboxing video
but i was trying to think of what is
something different that i could do
the specs are out there you've seen all
of the geekbench reports the screen
resolution is incredible there's no face
id there's no home button the new apple
pencil 2 is really fast
you can dock it you charge it it
connects automatically that's all
really great but i think one of the most
important things to take away from all
of this is
you don't really need the latest and
greatest tech to create
which is kind of ironic coming from
someone who loves having the latest and
greatest tech
but i started with basically nothing
i made most of my first youtube videos
12 years ago
kind of crazy to say that out loud on
just my computer with an eyesight camera
using the built-in microphone
that's it i think one of the things that
for me is important is
when you're creating don't be hindered
by what you don't have use what you do
have
and i wanted to introduce you guys to my
friend corey who i've known for a really
long time
basically before i even started my
youtube channel and i've sort of
followed his career
creatively and most recently he told me
that the ipad changed his life and i was
like
what tell me more so i sat him down for
interview hopefully we can get him to
say that the ipad changes life because
that's a really
really great quote anyway let me
introduce you to my friend corey
[Music]
i'm cory basil i'm an artist who does
fine art painting
illustrating uh writing novels poetry
i'm also a musician
i sing i write songs i play guitar i
play piano
i currently live in franklin tennessee
it's a little south of
nashville and every day i wake up in the
morning
i ask myself what can i make today
as much as i love working with
traditional mediums the apple products
have really revolutionized and changed
the way i do everything
and there's no way i could go back from
it the most recent thing i've done
is released two songs and the ipad came
in handy there i was able to
lay down voice memos of different ideas
and how i wanted to sing different looks
of the songs and i hand painted the
cover
traditionally with oil paint took a
picture with my iphone
put it in the ipad laid some text over
it and the cover is finished
but now that i have grown
it's so hard to see
past my mind
everything has fallen apart
i think one of the greatest misnomers is
people think that
success happens overnight and that's not
it at all
i think that all success began as a
failure
there's nothing wrong with taking risk
and failing it's actually
a quite beautiful thing to fail because
you learned and you get up and you try
again then when you're finally
successful you have
really a mountain of your own failures
to stand on top of
and it's uh it may sound negative but
it's a really beautiful thing
to look back and see how far you've come
and what you've worked through
and persevered i'm grateful for all the
challenges
in my journey as a creative and i
wouldn't have it any other way
oh okay cool
the liquid feature oh my gosh we get
we're out of here
just take a picture with your mind and
draw it later
the world was on fire and no one could
save me
but you
[Applause]
it's strange what desire will make
[Music]
we have been friends for such a long
time like very long time 2006
i think before i even started my youtube
channel that's correct that's a long
time
it's kind of cool because i feel like
i've been following your creative career
since
that time and you've done so many
different things how did you even get
started i mean i feel like you've been
into
art for like a very long time like since
you were little is that your first
passion
yeah art was first drawing as long as i
can remember
and wanted to be a disney animator when
i was a little kid then i saw my first
rock show when i was about 15 14 maybe
yeah and uh what was your first show
everything it was dc talk
wait okay so weren't you opening for
kevin max when i met you
yeah so kind of a full circle in many
ways
the digital transformation was amazing
first time i drew digitally it was on
one of those little tablets with the pen
and it was very minimal so it was
probably like a three by three
and i was just blown away that i could
draw and it would
translate so i got an ipad and the apple
pencil
and that changed everything i mean i use
it for almost everything
the only exception is photoshop which
i'm waiting for that to happen
that'll be so soon which is super
exciting yeah i mean 2019 i'm assuming
yeah i've written two books
on the ipad 110 000 word novel a lot of
poetry and short stories
done a slew of digital paintings i then
reproduce
prints of and sell those at my gallery
in franklin lay down
scratch ideas for songs and what do you
use for your illustrations
i use procreate i love pro cream so
that's cool because you showed me that
you can do time lapses
um this is my first piece trying out the
new ipad pro and the new apple pencil 2.
i titled this piece the boy who hung the
stars
tell them about the lunchbox justine
wanted a lunchbox so
we have a lunch box in the painting it's
a fish boy lunch box
what's fish boy fish boy is my novel the
pearl's a fish boy
and there's a lunchbox
[Music]
do you have a favorite piece that you've
created like on the ipad i think my
favorite piece is
called lost in an ice age it's got some
primitive graffiti work so you'll have a
gallery so people can come in and buy
things or see your work
uh yeah i've got a little gallery in
franklin tennessee
and it's appointment only or the first
friday of every month we have an art
walk which is really fun
and i have wine and donuts and great art
and there's a little trolley that goes
by my place to pick you up and take you
to other locations
yeah cool it's great and donuts and
donuts
i'm sold if any of you guys are in
franklin should definitely check it out
it's called imagine box emporium
i keep talking about how many things
you've done because it's just it is
really overwhelming i'm your graphic
designer i even remember
sending you my old flash files you guys
probably don't even know this but i used
to be a web designer and
i was really into actionscript and flash
and then you started getting into it
yeah i loved it
and i was having the hardest time
figuring out the mathematics or what
have you
of the animation and so you hit me up
and sent me a flash file
and i opened it i remember i just drew
this rough sketch of a guy and i opened
up the file and i
hit the space bar and the guy's eye fell
out and i was like i lost my mind
that's amazing it moved so you also just
released two songs
and i do feel like i don't know like a
lot of korean people i feel like go
through kind of like this
roundabout way to get back to something
that they've always loved to do
yeah and so for you you kind of were
into music and then kind of
pulled away from it kind of like
everything you just if there's a door
that
opens you just walk through it i've been
learning that more and more the older i
get that
we do as much as we can to try to plan
and plot out okay this is going to
happen this is going to happen what's
worked best is just
to you see a door open you just walk
through it and whatever happens happens
if the door shuts so be it another one
will open or maybe you're stuck in there
and you're somewhere cool
[Laughter]
well there's a window then i would leave
okay that's true i need windows
it's just crazy how technology has
really changed everything and i think
even for me too if people weren't doing
the things that i wanted so
it's like you make your own career path
and when people tell you no this isn't
something that
you can do or should do and you should
stop doing that it's like if you're
passionate enough
and you just don't quit i think that's
another thing that has
been interesting don't quit it's like
how are you feel it do it
yeah like how are you still making
youtube videos after like 12 years
because i haven't stopped and i've still
really loved what i'm doing and i think
that is important so if there is
something that you love doing and
it might not be working now i mean maybe
several years later
now you're releasing music and it's it's
super exciting i mean i was okay with
just
not going back to music yeah i mean i
have an old piano imagine that
he likes vintage
and i've always song written on the side
just
just to yeah to fulfill that inside of
me and
play my piano to take a break from
painting but uh i never thought that i
would
put anything out just kind of okay now
i'm doing the writing thing and i'm
doing the illustrating and fine art
painting and now i'm putting out music
again so you never know you don't
it's it's really cool i was just saying
that's cool
it was cool so you actually did a
painting for me and it's in my place and
i
i think we talked about doing this like
two years ago yeah so
i just recently got it it's amazing and
i feel like this is a different style
than what you're normally doing it's
like a
different thing uh i'd never been that
into abstract painting before
and uh i took three or four months and
used that time to fail over and over
again took the risk to discover what
abstract painting would be
for me yeah i studied color theory
how that worked how the balance works
composition work of others
so after all of that all the color study
i was able to
birth a whole new era of me it was
abstract work
and i thought who's gonna need this the
most who could use this who could
benefit from this vein of my work so i
decided to start a whole branch
and i call it maison basil and it caters
to
new home builds interior designers
businesses restaurants that kind of
thing
as far as inspirations go like who are
your biggest inspirations and art music
inspirations and music i've been
listening to a ton of sting
i thought you said stain i was like you
guys remember staying i do remember
staying me too my husband loves staying
in aubrey i used to be a big fan yeah
and it's been a while mike shinoda is
from lincoln park
and uh they were a big influence on me
not only
sonically musically chester's voice
all-time favorite just in the spirit of
how they wrote
lyrics and music to to really touch
people and to really hit people where
they are
and uh that's always been such a huge
part of why i write
and really all of my art is just to
touch a place in their heart that they
didn't
realize needed needed it you know both
hemingway and bukowski taught me to keep
it simple
painting caravaggio is my favorite
painter hands down
i feel a lot of similarities with van
gogh well thank you so much for sharing
i've always been so inspired
by just the massive amount of work that
you have created and i've always wanted
to tell your story so thank you guys so
much for watching make sure you go check
out corey
on instagram you're not on twitter
anymore
you're on facebook uh but go check it
out i'll put all of his links below
if you guys are in franklin or anywhere
nearby nashville how far is nashville
uh nashville's just 20 minutes up the
freeway oh cool
go check it out thanks for chatting with
us we'll see you guys later
thanks bye
[Music]
like a lot of it is self-taught as well
right yeah
all of it is
so i got an ipad with the eye pencil and
that
called the apple pencil
uh made the leap into the um
the ipad maybe he got an ipad
so i made the leap and i jumped into an
eye
pad so i got an ipad bro
okay so i got an ipad when did you get
that
when did i i got an ipad okay you got an
ipad
so you told me before
you got an ipad okay the sun's gonna go
down
so when did you get an ipad
is that my dog yeah it is my dog okay
so you got an ipad that's cool
okay ready yeah
show me
times
[Music]
oh
you